a Filipino fishing boat attempts to
enter the disputed Scarborough Shoals
main Lagoon but the Chinese Coast Guard
deploys rubber boats and Chase it away
Filipino fishermen say this has been the
situation in this part of the South
China Sea for years
we anchored there one time and the
rubber boat came and cut our anchors
and even if they can get past the
Chinese Coast Guard there is another
obstacle
Chinese have put up a floating barrier
which the Philippine Coast Guard says
could endanger the lives of those who
might try to break it if you're going to
insist in if you're going to insist in
proceeding to the show your propeller
could get stuck in the net that's
underneath the floating barrier
the Scarborough Shoal is about 120
nautical miles or 222 kilometers from
the Philippines Western province of
zambales its distance from China 900
kilometers
it was also the site of a standoff
between Manila and Beijing in 2012 after
the Philippine Navy arrested Chinese
fishermen the U.S brokered the deal and
the Philippine Navy pulled out but
Chinese vessels never left the resource
Rich Lagoon
experts say rising tensions could push
China to do more than just blocking off
entry into the show
Scarborough short is that one last
missing piece that is left for
reclaiming and to build a new Outpost
before Beijing could somehow you know
accomplish a more comprehensive coverage
of the area
Manila is also considering suing Beijing
again this time over what it says are
destructive practices that have led to
the death of coral reefs
that the Chinese Coast Guard are doing
this precisely to prevent our fishermen
from seeing what they're doing inside
the Shoal which is all of these
destructive fishing activity
but China says the accusations are
fiction and reiterated instead its
demand for the Philippines to tow away
its old warship on the second Thomas
show that it says is discharging
polluted water
below Al Jazeera Manila
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera